now just southeast of san diego is the
city of alpine great city with tons of
things to do with hiking local eateries
and a place to walk on the wild side and
if you thought the san diego zoo was the
only spot to meet exotic animals heather
lake has this next stop that sure to
surprise you
[Music]
time for a day trip in the quaint town
of alpine california and you can't
venture far without someone telling you
about the famous baked goods at crovin
cafe and bakery
i'm here at midnight every single day
everything's fresh baked when we open
the door at 5 30
things are literally just out of the
oven fresh and free of preservatives
croissants are key and the base for any
of the breakfast specialties in the menu
it's not meant to last it's meant to be
heated right away one of the owners is
from france and is bringing his culinary
expertise to locals and visitors alike
tucked in the cuyamaca mountains it's
the perfect spot for pre or post hike or
in our situation checking out the local
animal sanctuary and after you've fueled
up for the day you're gonna grab a
different kind of fuel and head out to
the mountains in alpine where this is
the only place you can get up close and
personal with a zebra the children's
nature retreat sits on 20 acres of land
they do private tours field trips and
every animal has a story we have about
145
different animals
all those animals need a home and i
promised them that it would be their
forever home they will have the best
life possible
we have horses we have a bison we have a
we have camels so we have a variety of
different animals also on site a maze
built out of 345 olive trees that are
growing and ready for kids to enjoy from
exotic animals to farm favorites the
children's nature retreat is a unique
environment where you get to interact
with these animals unlike any other what
i want them to learn is that how to
behave with animals how to love those
animals because the animals when you are
very nice to them they are super nice to
you
when you see our guests here everybody
has a smile on their face and that's
what we are really for i'm heather lake
in alpine for destination california